côté il ya des choses troublantes quand
madame houlette qui était la patronne du
pnh aujourd'hui en retraite dans la
ferme serment voilà sous serment devant
une commission denquête à l'assemblée
nationale dit qu'elle a subi des
pressions et pas n'importe quoi
c'est une femme qui est magistrat qui
parle sous serment elle sait ce qu'elle
dit et elle sait où elle le dit quand on
apprend par la presse
le point en l'occurrence que des écoutes
sont diligentées égard deux membres
éminents du monde des avocats sont
écoutés dans des procédures avec leurs
clients à la recherche soit disant d'une
taupe et
en dehors de procédure extrêmement
préoccupante
il ya de quoi s'inquiéter on se dit que
c'est parquet qui sont débarqués
spéciaux deviennent des parcs et
d'exception et on se demande comment ils
sont contrôlés et comment ça fonctionne
donc j'observe que le président de la
république a saisi le csm
le conseil supérieur de la magistrature
mais c'est inquiétant parce que le csm
il est saisi de nombreuses fois il ya
que 2 % de suite à sa saisine et quant à
madame bello b vient enfin de diligenter
une enquête
donc ça veut dire quand même qu'à ses
yeux il se passe quelque chose donc pour
vous le gouvernement est assez réactif
sur et bien le fonctionnement de ce pnf
et les enquêtes autour il aura fallu
attendre qu'ils aient des révélations et
par madame houlette et par la presse
sinon on aurait pas aujourd'hui la
réaction du garde des sceaux est ce
qu'il faudrait supprimer ce parc
national financiers ou alors le réformer
le rendre plus indépendant à l'évidence
et a un problème avec le monde
judiciaire et notamment avec le pnf et
je pense que ça mériterait un débat est
sûrement une réforme qu'on intègre ray
par exemple dans une révision de la
constitution sur l'indépendance du
parquet de manière générale voit pas ça
fait partie des projets qui avait déjà
été étudiées il ya quelques mois quand
on parlait d'une révision de la
constitution
en tout état de cause on va attendre les
résultats de ces interrogations de ses
enquêtes et je pense qu'il faudra que on
a au moins vers un début de réforme très
bien merci beaucoup
si hervé marseille d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
[Musique]